Hey youtubers, Monday in by Game of Thrones
Breakdown I asked you to submit all your questions
about season 4 and now it’s time for some
answers.
If you didn’t see it, I announced the countdown
video series I’ll be starting in March that
will end with my review of episode 1.
That will also be the beginning of my weekly
game of thrones giveaway.
It will be just like the one I’m doing for
Walking Dead right now.
If you’re finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to participate.
Super happy fun time with dragons starts in
about two weeks so get excited.
Now let’s get to your questions.
Number 1 - Reyne of Castamere (no avatar)
asks How are they going to explain Jaime returning
too early to Kingslanding?
and Is Bronn going to accompany Jaime to Riverrun
in order to completely fulfil Ilyn Payne's
role?
They’re not going to do anything special.
His story will just flow more from the events
of Feast For Crows.
There was the twincest shot and then if you’ve
read the books you know how his character
starts changing.
The Whitecloaks, Brienne and Oathkeeper.
And yes, Bronn as seen in the trailer, Bronn
is training him to fight with his left hand.
Since the character that plays Illyn Payne
is very sick with cancer they’re just giving
his scenes to Bronn.
So there will be exponentially more wisecracking.
Question Number 2 - All the world’s a stage
asks how deep into Dance With Dragons Feast
For Crows territory is season 4 pushing with
the characters like Brienne, Danerys, Bran,
and Theon, and what kind of pressure does
this put on GRRM to get "The Winds of Winter"
out there?
I don’t think it will cover the entire books.
Just like Season 3 didn’t do all of Clash
of Kings.
But I’d say based on the footage we’ve
seen they’ll get at least halfway through
books 4 and 5.
Just because both those books cover the same
period of time, just with different POV chapters.
The key in determining how far is looking
at the Sansa scenes.
Because of all the things in the trailer I
think that place she’s in happens after
that scene with Drogon at the end.
Question Number 3 - 7th Element asks Do you
think we'll see the Arya Faceless Ones narrative
explored this season?
The coin yes, but there has been no indication
that they filmed scenes in any place that
they don’t already have sets, with the exception
of Mereen.
So unless northern ireland where they film
the riverlands, crossroads scenes will be
doubling for the next place Arya goes, the
furthest we’ll get is her trying to use
the coin.
There’s been no evidence that they’ve
filmed scenes that chronologically occur after
that moment.
I would bet that if they stay true to the
books, the faceless ones will be a season
5 thing.
Question Number 4 - Link Carlton (no avatar)
asks how many more seasons realistically do
you think Game of thrones can go on for?﻿
They’ve plotted 7, but if HBO backs up a
dumptruck of money to their door they’ll
keep doing it.
But right now, they’ve tentatively said
they’d like 7 seasons.
Question Number 5 - Svc4Lyf69 (no avatar)
asks Who is or was your favorite character?
My favorite character always changes season
to season.
Last year it was a tie between Jaime and Brienne,
but based on what I know is going to happen
to his character, Jaime will probably be my
favorite this season.
Seriously, for those who have not read the
books.
Keep your eyes peeled on Jaime, he only gets
more interesting as the story progresses.
Question Number 6 - Mia Picoult asks In what
episode do you think the purple wedding will
be in?
Based on what I said in my breakdown and the
actors saying the wedding and the banquet
take up the entire story of one single episode,
I’d say number 4.
But it could be sooner.
It definitely won’t be the first episode.
And it will definitely be before Episode 5
and 6.
Question Number 7 - living like lannisters
asks do any book readers have an idea of what
that scene with Drogon is?
If you have Dance with Dragons, it’s the
scene that comes before this man brings Dany
a sack of bones.
This is from Chapter 11.
George RR Martin didn’t write that drogon
scene in the book.
We just learned about it from this old man.
So the show added it in, maybe just for the
sake of seeing drogon NOM an entire person.
Remember he only roasted someone last year,
but he’ll be big enough to flat out eat
someone this season.
Question Number 8 - Jessica Chaidee asks Do
you think we will see Lady Stoneheart in season
4?
The actress who would be playing her was on
suits for all of last year and has starred
in at least 4 movies since she left game of
thrones.
So there has been no evidence that she was
in northern ireland filming scenes.
Based on my earlier comment, that they’d
only get part way through books 4 and 5, it’s
possible that she could be in season 5 though.
Question Number 9 - Scarlett Moriarty asks
What scenes are you most excited for?
Big dragons, Jaime in Kings Landing and arya
and the hound in the riverlands.
Of all the characters that go through changes,
the biggest are the dragons.
They literally become a huge problem, Jaime
gets so much more interesting and Arya gets
super dark.
Plus I love the odd couple that she and the
hound make.
Their scenes are so much fun to watch.
Question Number 10 - yoda super fani (no avatar)
asks Do you post any character reviews?
I’ll be doing a month long count down video
series.
Since there will be so many Game of Thrones
videos happening in that time I’ll definitely
be doing character videos, history videos,
all kinds of stuff based on what you guys
want to see.
I know it will start in about two weeks, so
once we get closer I’ll start scheduling
which days which videos are going to be on.
If you have specific things you want to see
anyone can just let me know in the comments
and I’ll add it to my list.
Bonus Question The Mangese asks How close
to the book do you think the wedding scene
will be?
They went all out, Charles Dance who plays
Tywin said it felt like a short film it was
so complex.
So I would say they spared no expense and
bit of story.
Everyone keeps asking about dwarf jousting.
There will definitely be dwarves, but the
jousting bit is still a mystery.
Thanks so much everyone for submitting questions,
this was a lot of fun as always.
Remember the countdown videos start in about
two weeks, but until then I’ll probably
just do one game of thrones video a week.
I think this friday I’ll be doing a special
Hannibal Season 2 Preview for Valentine’s
day.
Would you please subscribe and be my dinner
date.
We will be eating all those people that you
don’t like.
Once I move to my new apartment I might even
try cooking some of the hannibal recipies,
sans people meats.
Right now click here for my season 4 breakdown
videos and click here for my latest walking
dead video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!